there's another thing also detective a
favor I would ask you to talk Barry out
every opening breaches to my earth I
can't do that
no you can't find a way to change his
mind for both our children's sakes look
I think it's just as done as you do but
I learned a long time ago I can't talk
Barry out of anything once she sets his
mind to it
zoom is terrorizing this other world
your world and he can't let it go
but look well you do me a favor
go a berry album Papa why would I do
that cuz he's got a much better chance
at defeating zoom if you're involved
you
hey youtubers it's Charlie so new
trailer for the flash if you guys didn't
know it is back this week it's called
versus zoom which already I just I love
that title but I'm mostly going to be
talking about why Harrison wells and Joe
are so awesome the whole premise of the
episode is that Barry has to find a way
to get back to earth-2 cisco is the key
to that they have to reopen the breaches
that in reopening a breach they also
give zoom a way back to earth 1 so
that's why Harrison wells is like please
convince Barry to not do this we need to
keep zoom on earth to where he can't get
to us here for the sake of our children
and the funny thing about this is when
he addresses Joe's child he uses the
singular tense so it's almost like he's
forgetting that Wally exists and I
actually I don't know if Harrison wells
knows about Wally he might not but there
are pictures of Wally being held up by
zoom from later in the episode so I'm
guessing that at some point Wally will
become fully aware of everybody at STAR
Labs on team flash invites versa but I
don't know necessarily that that's gonna
make him part a team flash yet all we
really know is that he's getting thrown
under the zoom bus so we'll have to wait
till after the episode airs to find out
we know what his relationship with team
flash is gonna be going forward because
usually you find out the hero's big
secret oh my god you're the superhero
that I look up to like on arrow when
people find out all of her secret
identity that doesn't automatically make
them part of team arrow but usually it
means that they're headed in that
direction so here's and wells just wants
to protect Jesse quick who's still kind
of roaming around earth 1 but she'll be
back before the end of the season he's
appealing to Joe as a father and I
actually think that's his more
interesting role in the show you
remember that he's a detective he's a
pretty good detective even though Wally
was shading him in an earlier episode
how good of a detective can you be if
you didn't know about me I think the
writers have done a good job of making
Joe a complicated character without
making him a shitty dad it's kind of
like he's a better version of the
character that Quentin Lance was meant
to be on arrow although technically he's
like the Commissioner Gordon because
they kind of modeled that show after
Christopher Nolan's Dark Knight trilogy
so naturally as the cop that ends up
working with the vigilante he's kind of
like the Jim Gordon but we can talk
about character problems in another
video I should probably make an arrow
video sometime this week because arrows
on break the Jesse Martin and Tom
Cavanagh don't really get a lot of
scenes together so I always get really
excited when they do because they're two
of the best actors on the show and two
of the more complicated characters so
when they get like a really awesome
scene
tends to be a little more rewarding than
say like them having scenes with other
characters like I love scenes with Joe
in Barry but it's really more of like a
father adviser talking to his son but
when he's talking to Harrison wells here
it's like they're acknowledging that
what they're doing probably isn't the
best thing but it's gonna happen anyway
so we just got to deal with it our
children
Barry Jesse quick they're gonna cause
all kinds of problems and there's
nothing we can do about it so we might
as well help them and the other big
message of this clip is that they have
to work together that's really a common
theme of any superhero TV show you know
you go rogue you're probably gonna fail
wait for the team do it together
you will succeed but what I'm really
worried about is how they're going to
keep Harrison wells on the TV show next
year without completely changing his
character like when they killed off
eobard thawne they essentially erased
earth-1 Harrison wells so when they
wanted to keep Tom Cavanagh on the show
they were just like well he's earth to
Harrison wells
so he's a completely different character
Tom Cavanagh still on the show but what
are they gonna do next year if they're
able to defeat zoom then there'll be no
more reason for him to hide out on earth
1 anymore he go back to earth 2 with
Jesse quick and they can resume their
lives there so here's my big question
for you guys let me know in the comments
how do you think that they're going to
keep Tom Cavanagh on the show do you
think they're going to defeat zoom at
the end of the season in Harrison wells
are just gonna be like well my home is
here now
so I'll stay here Jesse quake will find
a new home on earth 1 so it should be
like dad I don't want to go back to
earth-2 I want to stay here with all my
new friends where do you think it's
gonna be an arrow thing with Malcolm
Merlyn where like after season 1 Merlyn
went away for almost half a season then
he came back and was like surprised I'm
not dead they could do that but I feel
like another good reason to keep him
around on earth one is because they're
trying to deal with the multiverse now
like there are more problems related to
other Earth's so they need to keep the
team together to defeat you know
whatever big problem is gonna be
happening in season 3 we won't really
find out what that's gonna be till the
final episode usually in the finale
they tip their hat to whatever's gonna
be happening next season like at the end
of season 1 the giant wormhole opened
that was going to eat the earth it
opened breaches to earth - thus we met
zoom so it's gonna be a while before we
find out what season 3 is going to be
about a lot of it's gonna depend on what
the solution to defeating zoom is but
tomorrow night big zoom backstory so be
sure to watch the episode I'll post
my video after it airs be sure to
subscribe to get that and there is a new
round of the flash giveaway all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and
leave a comment on this video it's
really like a DC giveaway so it'll just
stay open until I post my last DC video
this week Supergirl is also having its
finale tonight I haven't really planned
a video but if they do something really
crazy then I'll totally do a video for
it tomorrow you know the big news is
they actually just dropped some Game of
Thrones footage as I was making this
video like literally as I was making
this flash video new Game of Thrones
season 6 so I'll post a video for that
later tonight if you guys haven't seen
it Kevin Feige was teasing a bunch of
phase 4 changes just how different it
was going to look so you can click here
to learn all about Marvel's face for
movies and you can click here to learn
all about what the actor who plays zoom
was talking about the finale thank you
so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight